hello everyone we are in Austin for
South by Southwest and we're doing some
interviews thanks to Commissario tequila
right now we have to thank them because
it's a challenge and it's expensive to
come to festivals and this gives us the
opportunity to talk about movies like
the day shall come thank you guys so
much for being here today welcome first
off because I feel like you could read a
brief synopsis about the movie and not
really get the full gist of what you're
diving into so can you give a brief
description of what this movie is about
and also who you're playing in it yes
so I Marcia Davis and playing Moses who
is a self-proclaimed street prophet who
is trying to lead his mission and is
trying to save the farm from being he's
trying to save the farm from getting
evicted he's being evicted so he finds
an unlikely ally in the FBI which leads
him into some circumstances that he did
not expect and this is based on true
occurrences right yeah well hey yeah I'm
Daniele Brooks I played Venus who is
Moses's wife in the film and basically
she's his rock his the one that is
basically his moral compass and trying
to make sure that they don't get evicted
too but anyway this movie is really
about survival um I think and and it is
based off roughly based off other
stories you know Chris had Chris Morris
a director has seen or an article that
really struck him about these like
construction Haitian workers that had
been tricked into this whole corrupt
investigation thing with the FBI and
basically had to spend 25 years in
prison and because of that he was so
intrigued by that story that he decided
to write his own story so it definitely
is based off you know stories that have
happened yeah I think Chris likes to say
it's based
100 true stories and I think that's
that's like facts because he's he
interviewed so many people some of which
we got to meet to sort of bring together
this tapestry of a story that you'll see
why was it important for you guys to
sign on to this what was it that drew
you to the project because one of the
things that I appreciate about the
movies that I'm covering at South by and
you know something like this in
particular is seeing things on the big
screen gives people access to stories
and other people's experiences that they
might not be aware about for me it was
really Chris Morris cuz I didn't know
what I was doing to be honest we barely
got the script I kind of didn't even get
the script until after I had gotten the
part so I didn't know what I was
stepping into and I had to fully put my
trust in him but knowing that you know
he was very respected in this business
he had won a BAFTA for four lions I was
like okay I'm a rock with him and after
I met him I was like oh yeah I'd like
his style and how he talks and works
with actors and was like I'll give it a
shot I'm so curious how did that happen
then do you have an agent or a manager
who says you know this person wants to
work with you they say yes or no and
that's it yeah it was this you know the
casting director had reached out was
looking for someone like myself and yeah
you have a conversation with your agent
about what the project potentially could
be but I really had no idea what this
was gonna be and I had to go in kind of
blinded but really holding my hand out
because I trusted Chris and one of the
most exciting things I mean as an actor
to be able to like go into an audition
and not have to think about the lines
you just get to go in and play so I
think at Chris sort of like foster that
environment when we were on set a lot so
we we we didn't have much information to
go off when we first got the script but
then I got the script after I get people
ask me when did what you felt about that
wood I thought about the the film when I
first saw it and I didn't I didn't get
the script until I got the job so in the
script was forever changing this we
actually got the script we actually went
back for reshoots and everything so
Wow so what was it like going from the
audition and not having the script you
getting the script to then seeing the
final film because you know I'm thinking
about four lines and that's that's
actually another movie that I can't
quite describe to someone you need to
see it to feel that vibe for yourself so
were you guys surprised about anything
in the final film surprised I you know I
would say this the one thing I love
about Chris and his work is that like
especially with this project it's like
it started out as this like egg and then
it turned into like this toddler and
then we had like this young adult and
then we have an adult which you'll see
tonight if you come to the premiere it's
like ever morphing ever changing and I
think when the audience sees it they'll
add on a new aspect that we didn't see
before is there anything in particular
that you two took from this story or
just this experience making the movie
some I'm sure there's a variety of
responses someone could have but fer
personally what did you guys take from
this that comedies can have consequences
that yes you can
yes I don't think it's trying to make
fun of the FBI but I think it is poking
fun at injustice and I didn't I didn't
think I could laugh at it before and
that I watched it I'm like oh sure that
it that that is actually funny the
mechanism in which some of these people
are like prosecuted it's it's ridiculous
before I wrap up couple rapid-fire
questions for you harmless questions
good fun what TV show would you most
like to guest star on the dirt the
comodo yeah but you see you get a pass
what movie do you quote the most
probably
but no like I mean if I didn't do like I
don't know what is the worst job you
ever had working in a restaurant I hate
I worked at a experience called sleep no
more what is the background photo on
your phones it's inspiring if that's
what's important to you you got a lot of
pictures of you mines is a picture of a
dog called Limpy that my friend Kerry
fed when I taught in Guatemala yes he
brought them back to life pictures I
love pictures and not like Instagram
pictures but like actual pictures we
just left another place and we got to
take Polaroids and like it's so much fun
I love pictures children's books
no we're but I love children now no you
know there's just something to have such
great messages like you know the Monster
at the End of this book the one with
Grover
you don't know it cause clearly you like
look at me like my favorite is um are
you my mother my favorite I remember
that one is when the bird is looking for
his mom and he goes to like a
construction truck and he goes to like a
dog he goes to everything and he finally
finds his mom it's really sweet and
inspiring and it sends good messages and
that's the way we have to wrap this up
on a high note the day shall come keep
an eye out for it thank you guys so much
for your time today congratulations on
the movie thank you so much to our
wonderful sponsors for letting us be
here today like and share this interview
and we will see you soon with more at
South by
Southwest interviews
you